The jogan Experience what do you think
is the most difficult of all these
things you've ever done
um maybe the
ice hard just on the
mind yeah that one was the worst one I
would never do that again how long did
it take your brain to recover from that
the brain recovers pretty fast I think
after one night's sleep I was okay
really the brain yeah so no more
hallucinations yeah but also I was I was
yeah it was it was bad I would worry
about something like that that I would
open up a door that I could never
close yeah that would be that would be
like in a in a horror movie that would
happen that's why I don't mess with
sleep deprivation I tried to mess with
it yeah it's scary yeah I think it's a
very effective form of torture I think
in North Korea they did that to the
American extreme sleep deprivation I
think that tweaked them the the worst oh
I'm sure we do it too yeah guano Bay
yeah sleep deprivation is horrific yeah
isn't it crazy it's horrible cuz that's
when you wouldn't even think of his
torture when you think of people think
of his torture they think of pain you
know they don't think of just like
making someone stay awake well but
that's isn't that Chinese water torture
they just drip water in your face I
don't think that one's so bad really I
don't think so I heard it's pretty bad I
don't know I think there's something
about it that just keeps you awake and
it's just nuts because you're just the
drip and like it
being irregular interval micro sleep I
don't know I don't think so maybe you
should try that one do you want to see
this trick I would love to see this
trick what do you got well it's a simple
one but it's a new one so I just use
some thread but I might need your help
Okay um do you want to come closer I'll
come over there yeah should I can move
should I move over or you can come here
I'll come over there should I slide to
the left or
something so first I'll show you the
trick version wait can I take this off
yeah so first I'll show you the trick
version of it okay which is just like
this for the people just listening at
home uh he folded over a little Loop in
a piece of thread yeah
and he's putting it in his mouth and
swallowing
it he's chewing on the thread now he's
drinking
water yeah I think it's here
wait hold on so this is a trick
version you see you get
um see you can pull here I don't know if
you can see can you do you want to just
pull it pull the thread so you have a
thread that you stuck in your but see
uhhuh so that's the trick
version that's a thread that he just had
embedded in his skin but hold on here's
the different
version actually
wa
I'm
instead I'll do it this
way so you can see what's actually
happening
wait all you grab here the one under
your chin okay so now he's got a thread
coming out from under his chin pull it
up a little
okay pull it down
it's uh through his mouth and through
the bottom of his mouth and out his chin
and pull want me pull it out
yeah
okay so that's something that I learned
in India so you just essentially use a
needle and shove it through the bottom
of your jaw and and people think it's
coming out of your mouth yeah it's
pretty good though it is pretty good
I'm G to go to the other
side so it's a there's a there's a book
called Swami Mantra and how you getting
it into your chest well there's first
I'll tell you there's a book called
Swami Mantra which is a collection of
pamphlets of Secrets of what the fakir
were doing in India so there was a trick
that I saw a magician do when I was a
kid and he ate a thread and he pulled it
out of his stomach and I was with a
bunch of amazing magicians and we were
all blown away and in shock but I
cornered the guy and convinced him to
teach me the secret so then I I started
playing with it and and then just now
when I was in India Meeting Street
magicians and finding all these
performers I went to a festival and they
do all these extreme things I have never
seen before like they pushed the The Ice
Pick skewer type thing through their
neck through their and so suddenly had
an idea and I was like wait maybe
there's a way and
then yeah and then it becomes a magic
trick but you're seeing the early phase
of of it okay
yeah sometimes I get nervous at like uh
you know obviously anything could go
wrong you could you know yeah start
squirting
blood like it happened last time yeah
well I promised you there was going to
be blood thank
you